et ce soir dans son allocution jean
castex à nouveau encouragé le
télétravail mis en place dès le 1er
confinement déjà autorisé par la loi ils
s'installent etd travailler encore plus
dans nos vies professionnelle et privée
il a d'abord provoqué l'enthousiasmé
beaucoup pointent aujourd'hui ses
inconvénients
alors le télétravail véritable progrès
ou bien danger pour les salariés la
bible télétravail nuit-il à la santé on
en parle tout de suite avec un autre
économiste jacques sapir bonsoir jacques
bonsoir c'est fini alors c'est donc une
des conséquences de la crise sanitaire
un l'essor de ce télétravail pas trop
malheureux de devoir télé travailler
avec nous d'ailleurs jacques ça vous
concerne derrière votre ficus devenue
célèbre souris bercy peu cool
noro bas je prends mon mal en patience
alors oui vous avez tout à fait raison
le coc vide lakovic 19 n'a pas créé le
télétravail mais elle a
incontestablement contribué à leur
répondre de manière à tout à fait
considérable ainsi il y avait 4 % des
salariés qui avaient recours au
télétravail
avant la crise sanitaire et il y en a eu
pratiquement 1 sur 4 pendant le premier
confinement alors au départ ce qui est
intéressant c'est que pratiquement les
trois quarts des français qui étaient en
télétravail été très heureux de le faire
entre le cadre disait que cela leur
convenaient bien et c'était la même
chose du point de vue des entreprises
si vous voulez les entreprises voyaient
que le télétravail pouvait être
l'occasion pour elle de réduire leur
loyer après le fantasme de lusine cents
ouvriers et bien on avait le fantôme de
l'entreprise de bureaux sans bureaux
alors on définitif ce télétravail qui
concerne t-il alors vous avez tout à
fait raison de poser cette question et
c'est un des premiers problèmes auxquels
on est confrontés en réalité on voit que
le télétravail
il est extrêmement concentré sur
certaines régions on le voit par exemple
pour le premier conte
finement alors je vous le redis la
moyenne des travailleurs s'étaient 24 %
des travailleurs qui étaient en
télétravail
or qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit qu'ils
étaient 44% dans la région ile de france
c'est tout à fait considérable
al'inverse ils sont évidemment beaucoup
moins nombreux dans d'autres régions
comme les pays de loire les hôtes france
ou la normandie
donc ça prouve qu'il y a une très grande
disparité entre régions sur cette
question du télétravail alors il est
clair jacques que toutes les professions
ne se prête pas de la même manière on en
sait quelque chose au télétravail
oui c'est une évidence on comprend bien
que le télétravail n'a pas vraiment sa
place dans l'industrie dans le bâtiment
évidemment dans la construction bon mais
il n'a pas non plus sa place dans des
professions qui implique un contact
personnel par exemple ou une présence
physique le cas des transports
évidemment mais aussi le cas de
l'agriculture voire du commerce de
proximité
en fait ce sont essentiellement les
travailleurs du tertiaire qui sont
concernés alors il n'y a t'il jacques un
lien entre la taille de l'entreprise et
l'importance du télétravail oui tout à
fait c'est quelque chose que l'on a
remarqué alors même si c'est de manière
un petit peu indirects on a vu
effectivement que le télétravail se
développe et surtout dans des
entreprises de taille moyenne ou de
petite taille
alors quand je dis que c'est un un
indicateur induits c'est que on a un
consulter un petit peu des statistiques
qui regardent la demande en nouveaux
outils numériques par exemple les
logiciels de téléconférence et bien ce
qu'on a vu c'est que le nombre de
travailleurs qui ont eu besoin de
s'équiper avec ces nouveaux outils
il est effectivement beaucoup plus
important dans les entreprises disons de
taille moyenne entre 250 et 1000 et
émile salariés alors qu'est ce que ça
nous donne ça nous donne un portrait
type en fait du télétravailleur c'est
une femme ou un homme travaillant dans
le tertiaire
employé dans une entreprise plutôt de
taille moyenne de plusieurs dizaines
voire de plusieurs centaines de
personnes
et résidant essentiellement ou en région
parisienne ou dans une grande métropole
comme lyon marseille ou strasbourg
alors la question quels avantages trouvé
ton au télétravail lors de ce premier
confinement là aussi c'est un point
intéressant c'est qu'il ya eu plusieurs
études les études en france des études
internationales
et qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que de
ce point de vue là les travailleurs eux
ils voyaient dans le télétravail tout
d'abord une manière générique
d'améliorer la gestion de leurs horaires
ou de pouvoir avoir un cadre travail de
travail plus agréable que le bureau par
exemple pour les entreprises
c'était plutôt les avantages qui
concernait la réduction des dépenses
quotidiennes pour l'entreprise voit un
accroissement apparent de la
productivité
seulement avec la fin du premier
confinant les opinions ont commencé à se
réajuster et ça c'est un point qui est
extrêmement intéressant en fait au début
du mois d'octobre dernier c'est au
moment où on a commencé à se reposer la
question d'un possible reconfirme ans eh
bien on s'est aperçu que le nombre de
travailleurs qui étaient en télétravail
et est passé de 24 % à 14 % dont en fait
seulement 4 % avaient recours de manière
intégrale c'est à dire cinq jours par
semaine au télétravail il y avait donc
eu un recul très net de ce que le
premier ministre jean castex que tu
avais un peu imprudemment qualifié de
phénomène de société ou de révolution
dans la manière de travailler
et pourquoi ce changement alors il est
intéressant de regarder les raisons qui
ont amené les entreprises à prendre un
petit peu de distance justement avec
cette question du télétravail a tout
d'abord les responsables se sont mis à
craindre que malgré des systèmes
informatiques intrusif qui sont parfois
utilisés de ne pas pouvoir contrôler
leurs salariés vous savez ce n'est pas
un hasard si les open space se sont
multipliées dans les bureaux depuis une
vingtaine d'années les open space
ils ont pour fonction d'organiser le
contrôle sur les salariés
après les entreprises se sont rendu
compte
avec le télétravail elle perdait cette
capacité qu'avait leurs salariés de se
rencontrer d'échanger des idées de
pouvoir même cédé pour effectuer
certaines tâches
en fait les entreprises ont réalisé que
le télétravail pourrait aussi avoir des
conséquences néfastes à la fois sur
l'innovation et sur la productivité des
salariés
alors on comprend effectivement alors
pourquoi les entreprises à son sont plus
grandes sont présentes mais n'y at il
pas aussi des réticences du côté des
salariés
oui oui vous avez tout à fait raison
stéphanie en fait on voit qu'il y à
plusieurs risques qui sont apparus pour
les salariés avec cette extension du
télétravail premier risque évidemment
c'est le risque d'isolement social c'est
aussi le risque est lié au fait que le
télétravail fait disparaître la
frontière entre la vie professionnelle
et la vie privée du salarié
et puis il ya ensuite l'ensemble des
risques qui sont induits par la pression
sur le salarié lié aux objectifs des
objectifs qui d'ailleurs ne peuvent plus
être discuté aussi facilement qu'au
bureau enfin et ça ça semble assez
évident mais visiblement les gens l'ont
redécouvert il ya tous les problèmes
matériels liés à l'équipement
informatique du travailleur lié aussi à
l'espace dont on dispose chez soi pour
pouvoir travailler
il est clair que ces conditions
matérielles joue beaucoup aujourd'hui
dont le ressenti par rapport au
télétravail et pourtant ces questions
ont fait l'objet d'un accord récent oui
tout à fait tout est fait c'est fini ces
problèmes ont eu un début de
reconnaissance avec l'accord qui a été
signé le 27 novembre dernier entre les
organisations patronales et des
organisations syndicales un accord qui
vise en particulier à prévenir le
harcèlement du salarié par son employeur
mais cet accord n'est en fait que le
début de la reconnaissance des problèmes
liés au télétravail
donc il faudra aller nettement plus loin
et puis et puis il ya quand même un gros
problème c'est qu'il faut le savoir
les les problèmes qui sont liées
justement au télétravail
eh bien il donne faim dix ans il donne
naissance à une interrogation quant à la
santé des travailleurs
pourquoi ces interrogations alors là
encore c'est une intéressante et où on
peut croiser des données qui viennent
d'études canadiennes d'études qui ont
été faites sur la france on voit très
bien qu'il ya eu des problèmes alors
entre ce que j'avais cité comme l'
isolement où le chevauchement entre la
vie privée et la vie professionnelle
il ya aussi la montée des tensions au
sein des équipes une fois que son passé
en télétravail
pourquoi parce que on s'est rendu compte
que la communication par voix d'écran
favorise justement cette montée des
conflits par une étude qui est des fêtes
parra cabinet d'expertisé français le
cabinet syndex qui montrait d'ailleurs
que la crise avait amplifié le risque si
les psychologues et les risques
psychosociaux dans les entreprises il ya
aussi le risque de montée des addictions
en tous genres alcool cigarettes etc
on doit d'ailleurs rattaché à cela la
montée qui est assez effrayante de la
consommation de psychotropes que l'on
constate d'ailleurs depuis ces dernières
semaines
alors tout cela tout ceci porte un nom
ça s'appelle la désocialisation des
personnes en situation de télétravail et
on a tendance quand même l oublier le
travail en présentiel si vous voulez le
fait d'aller sur son lieu de travail
justement
et bien c'est un facteur majeur dans la
socialisation des individus donc en gros
le télétravail n'est pas bon pour la
santé jacques et non et non et c'est
quelque chose dont on pourra se rendre
compte lors en même temps il faut bien
mesurer les paradoxes du télétravail
pour des personnes qui ont un niveau
d'éducation très élevés qui sont dans le
bonne condition qu'ils font un travail
intéressant par exemple le basculement
vers le télétravail a été à l'évidence
une opportunité fructueuse
de même pour certaines entreprises dont
les entreprises ou les tâches sont des
tâches qui sont essentiellement des
tâches hinault
et qui peuvent faire confiance justement
à leurs salariés
de ce point de vue là et bien
effectivement le télétravail a pu être
aussi une bonne opportunité
la majorité des travailleurs du
tertiaire comme pour la majorité des
entreprises concernées et bien le
télétravail s'avère être un piège et il
faudra donc certainement à l'avenir
encadrées et limitées très probablement
cette pratique
alors oui pour répondre à votre question
le télétravail et bien non ce n'est pas
bon pour la santé
et cela peut conduire justement à cette
fameuse désocialisation d'une grande
partie des personnes concernées et bien
jacques dans ce cas prenez soin de vous
puisque vous êtes en télé travail et
merci pour cet éclairage à la semaine
prochaine